As a pot of tea cools, the temperature
the tea is modeled by a differentiable
function h.
For 0 is less than or equal to, t is less
than or equal to 10.
Where time t is measured in minutes.
And temperature h of t is measured in
degrees Celsius.
Values of h of t, at selected time,
selected values of time
t are shown in the table above, so that's
right over there.
Use the data in the table to approximate
the rate at which
the temperature of the t is changing at
time t equals 3.5.
Show the computations that lead to your
answer.
So, they give us a bunch of points, so
let's just graph this,
just so we can visualize what this data's
telling us a little bit.
And, I suspect that this might be useful,
so, this, right over here, is our
temperature axis.
This is our temperature at any moment, in
degrees Celsius.
And then, this is our time axis, and they
gave us the time of 0 2 5 9 and 10.
They give us a temperature of those times.
So, this is 0.
2, 5's A little bit further.
5, 9, And then 10.
And at time zero, the temperature's 66
degrees, Celsius.
66, So it's right over there.
At time 2, it is 60 degrees Celsius.
At time two, it is 60 degrees celsius.
At time 5, it is 52 degrees Celsius.
So time 5, maybe it's right over here,
this is 52 degrees Celsius.
At time 9, or after 9 minutes, I should
say, it's at 44 degrees Celsius.
So this 44 degrees Celsius, and after 10
minutes it's 43 degrees Celsius.
So this is really just a graph showing how
it
cools off over those ten minutes, over
those ten minutes.
That's what the data is telling us.
It's kind of a curve like this, and we've
sampled it at these points.
So going back to Part A.
Use the data in the table to approximate
the rate at which
the temperature of the tea is changing at
time t equals 3.5.
So the rate of change is really just a
slope
of this curve at time t is equal to 3.5.
So really, we just wanna find the slope at
that point right over there.
We wanna find the slope, and we don't know
the actual function.
So the best way to approximate the slope
at that point, is
really just find the slope, between, time,
between minute five, and minute two.
So the rate of change, so we could say, we
could say that the rate, the
rate, is going to be approximately, our
change
in temperature over that, over those three
minutes.
So, h of 5 minus h of 2, and this is
obviously going
to be in degrees Celsius, over the number
of minutes that changed, so we
went from 5 minutes or from, we end at 5
minutes, and we started
at 2 minutes, and so the rate, the rate is
going to be approximately.
At five minutes, our temperature is 52
degrees, 52 degrees.
At two minutes, our temperature is 60
degrees, 60 degrees.
And then, this is over change in three
minutes.
5 Minus 2 is 3.
So, this gets us, let me just pull to the
right a little bit,.
This gives us negative 8.
Negative 8 degrees Celsius over three
minutes.
Or the rate at, the rate at, at three and
a half
minutes is going to be approximately
negative 8 3rds, degrees Celsius per
minute.
So that is part a, part a.
And then part b, using correct units,
explain the
meaning of 1 over 10, 1 over 10, times
the definite integral from 0 to 10 of h of
t dt in the context of this problem.
Use a trapezoidal sum with the 4
sub-intervals
indicated by the table to estimate this
thing.
So, the integral from 0 to 10 of h of t is
really the area of this entire, under this
curve, right over here.
That's the integral, that's this part
right over here.
And then, we're going to divide that.
We're going to divide that by.
We're going to divide that by 10.
So, what this is really giving us.
This is.
This expression, right over here.
Is the average,
this is the average temperature.
This is the average temperature over that
time period.
The integral of the temperature function
divided by the
total amount of time that has, that has
elapsed.
And then, in using correct units, well
it's the average temperature
and the average temperature is once again
going to be in degrees.
Degrees Celsius.
And it makes sense, cuz this right over
here is in degrees Celsius.
You're multiplying it by time right over
here, but then you could divide by.
You're dividing, I'm assuming, by time
right over here
as, so this is times minutes, divided by
minutes.
So then you just get degrees Celsius
again.
So this is, this expression right over
here
is just the average temperature over those
ten minutes.
They they say use a trapezoidal sum with
the
four sub intervals indicated by the table
to estimate this.
So, a trapezoidal sum is, we don't know
the
exact function here, so we won't be able
to
analytically evaluate this definite
integral, but what we can
do is divide, is divide this area into
four sections.
They tell us to use this, four
subintervals.
And, we'll essentially divide it into four
trapezoids.
So, this is one trapezoid right over here.
So this is one trapezoid right over there.
That's my first trapezoid from zero to two
on the base.
And you see on the left end of that
trapezoid is height of 66 the right end is
60.
And the the next trapezoid will go from
two to five.
Let me do that in a more.
Color that contrast a little bit better.
The next trapezoid will go from 2 to 5.
The next trapezoid goes from 2 to 5.
And then the third trapezoid goes from,
goes from 5 to 9.
The third trapezoid goes from 5 to 9.
And then, the fourth trapezoid goes from 9
to 10.
Goes from 9 to 10.
And so if I want to.
If I want to approximate the definite
integral part right here, before we
divide by 10, I just need to find the area
of these four trapezoids.
So, let's do that.
The area of this first trapezoid is going
to
be the base, which is 2 times the average
height.
The height if the left side for this
trapped is 66.
The height on the right side of this
trapezoid is 60.
The average height right over here is
going to
be 63, just the average of 60 and 66.
So, this area right over here is, this is
126,
that's the area of the green part right
over there.
By the same logic, the area of this orange
part.
I want to do that in the orange color.
The area of this orange part, the base
right over here is 3.
Base is 3.
And then the average height.
The height over here is 60.
The height over here is 52.
This is, they're seated 8 apart, so the
average is going
to be 4 away from each is going to be 56.
So this is, the area here is going to be 3
times, 3 times 56.
Which is 150 plus 18.
150 Plus 18 is 168.
That's the area of this orange trapezoid,
and then the area of this blue trapezoid.
The base right over here is 4, and then
then average height, the height here is
52, the height
here is 44, the average of 52 and 44, let
see they're 10, they are, sorry, they are
8 apart.
So then it's just gonna be 4 from each of
these so it's 48, so
the average height here is 48, and so 4
times 48 is 160 plus 32.
So it's 192, and then finally this last
trapezoid, it's base is only 1.
Its base right over here is only 1, and
then its
height is 43 at the left side, 43 at the
right side.
So its average height is 43.5, 43.5.
So it's 43.5 times 1.
So that's just going to be 43.5, and so if
we add up the areas under,
or the areas of all these trapezoids, we
have a pretty good approximation for the
definite integral.
I'll just use, do the.
Use the calculator for this part right
over here.
So we have 126, plus 168, plus 192, plus
43.5, 43.5.
Gives us 529.5.
So this is equal to 529.5.
And so that's our
approximation for the definite integral
part.
But then we also have to divide it by 10,
or we have to multiply time 1 10th.
So we've evaluated, so this part right
over here, we got 529.5 as our
approximation.
It's not going to be exact, but using the,
using
the trapezoidal sum, the sum of the areas
of these trapezoids.
And now we have to multiply by 1 10th, so
lets do that.
So, or we could just divide by 10, which
actually we don't need a calculator for
that, 52.95.
So this whole thing, this whole thing
evaluates to 52.95,
and I'll do the next two parts in the next
video.